POWER PLAY.
SLICK MOVE BY SANDIN,, ON THE P!
>> Craig: FIRST IN 47 GAMESINS
BATTLE AND THAT ONE SLIDES
UNDERNEATH AS Y Horn MOVING, MA
.
HERE'S CHABOT  AGGRESSIVE HERE.
CHABOT, ALL 33
YEARS OF AG THE PENALTY
KILL.
WATCH WHAT SPEED DOES HERE.OINT
OVER TO MARNER ON HIS STRONG
SIDE.
THREE-ON-TWO
OTTAWA, BRANNSTROM, BACKHAND AND
THAT WENT , AND THAT IS
TURNED ASIDE BY MURRAY.
MARNER THE  SCORES BYHABOT DOES
HIS STICK.
PU
GAUDETTE, CAMPBELL PLAYS THAT.
BRODIE, A LEAD FEED, THAT'S
ENGVALL IN BEHIND -
THERE'S A CHANCE FOR FORMENTON
IN FRONT!
OH WHAT STICK OF BRODIE AND
THEN THE TOE OF FOR TORONTO.
>> Chris: HOLDEN, AND TIERNEY I
CAMPBELL IS IT'S BEEN A
DIFFICULT GAME FOR HIM BECAUSE
HE HASN'T BEEN ALL THAT WORK, G
TO MARNER, IN FRONT, AND MURRAY
STUDIO ABOUT MATTHEWS BEING ABLE
TO TURND
A TWO-ON-ONE BREAK FOR THE
LEAFS.
HIM BUT NYLANDER DOESN'T GET
THERE QUICK ENOUGH TO NEGATE TR
AND JASON SPEZZA BACK, GAVE
>> Craig: THEREIS LEGS MOVING A
DETERMINED A GAPING
A SIX-GAMET
STREAK, SCORES AGAIN!
WIWIE THE
PUCK WAS.
LOO B B
BACK IN.
CHECKED BY KERFOOT.
AND AWAY GOES MIKHEYEV.
HE'S HAVE
YOU TO RESPECT THE PADS.
YOU GET A TURNO